hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the markiplier quiz game
made by a fan featuring questions from
my youtube life or at least that's as
far as I know and I thought to myself
when I saw this game how could I
possibly screw up a quiz that's about me
so let's find out exactly how that can
happen because I'm assuming that I'm not
gonna be grow enough to beat this game
yes what was the title of markiplier its
first video on the market our game
channel and easy oh that's it should
server off to Ray I'm gonna die I think
if it's not that one it might have been
the reaction Coble II I don't remember
what I had loaded first because when I
came to this channel I reapplied it
everything what game was mark playing in
the first video included face game and
needs your abduction it was like episode
8 or 9 or something which of these games
has mark not done a let's play for the
sims 3 I played it myself a lot but
never done it before what did mark do
for a sound subscriber special this
cinnamon challenge and by the way if
they're referential videos I'll probably
include an annotation for him or in the
description if you want to check him out
according to mark what is his slogan
king of this weight is a douche like a
muse up take these cuz I lost my own
game and don't know my own life doesn't
mean you need to call me a loser like a
loser like okay so this one Oh God oh
not that one shudders oh really that's
my slogan according to me which of these
games is a mark of our mod exist for oh
I wish chicken walks SB speed could bid
with favorably with what game has
without a doubt made markiplier rage the
hardest oh that's a good question not
that one not that one not that one not
any of these names the one that would
say raised the hardest ohh
ah punishment the punishing that sounds
pretty bad
yay oh ho marking match is my alter ego
let's get some Marquis mash fanart up in
there
ooh nice and blurred out for the little
kitties to enjoy earn not be scarred for
life or I should say Watford word fish
what is the bet oh I just didn't sketch
comedy with wolveroach - whilst indigo
is here Nellie what is the best strategy
for prop 1 become a become a giant prop
stuck in other props exactly what is
Barca buyers most viewed video margul
are highlights number 6 which of these
games did Mark enjoy the least oh come
on oh I know evil by far was the last
game mark Bob and Wade played during the
12 hour farewell just go dodgeball
yeah I got getting it I know me I know
me enough to win a quiz about me I'm the
greatest person ever yay
v markiplier highlights video had what
seemed oh that was about yamimash oh my
god of course cuz me and Yami must have
done so much
let's get that marquee match fan art
back in okay let's push that out of
there River where was Mark not born wow
this is really specific about my life
why do you know so much about me
I'm not born in Cincinnati what
instrument what instrument did Mark lay
in his high school band the electric
triangle [ __ ] yeah
I love to play the electric triangle but
no I'd love to mark Slee like you're
trying to kill everybody in the whole
band the trumpet which of these games
cause mark to stop playing because it
was so terrifying that would be dread
all's i was on the oculus rift and it
literally made me cry if you want to see
me cry check out the annotation over
there in the first episode of drunk
minecraft what happened when Mark asked
for TNT I got it
wait oh god mark out TNT button wait
kill mark and took oh that's right riser
thank you goodbye I will call me a loser
me I'm not a loser
Oh winner
winner baby okay did that happen ah okay
can I get a stick oh oh that's why Bob
and Wade got T and D that's right okay
well game was mark playing the first
let's play he recorded with an oculus
dumpee going elephants which is still by
far the best oculus rift or game not
horror game wasn't a horror game even
those those little kids were awfully
terrifying not a horror game don't be
going elephants we do these games and
Mark put the most time into editing oh
my god Octodad of course I put so much
work into that entire series it took
mark 9 episodes to be short your mouth I
still paid it a lot of people out there
have never beaten it so shut up which of
these things is true about mark uh wait
a minute he was that I was an accident
yeah of course my parents were on like
10 different times of birth control what
year was marked born in uh yeah what do
these games is wow this is so weird is
this weird that I'm doing a quiz by
myself and I'm still getting things
wrong ah
does Mark play alone happy wheels which
of these youtubers have not done a visit
rub a snowman what a cool guy
I wish oh this should be easy the one
that's obviously designed to succeed
but that one which is a boat is freakin
awesome I love that Bing
where's the black you son of a [ __ ] I
will murder your face honk your
blacksmith hey I get invited him ah
little kid bastard kid Scott this guy
whoever means it's thank you so much you
know a lot about me and that's kind of
creepy but also kind of Awesome
what markiplier series has the most
videos Oh God
drunk minecraft I think that's a winner
what do these series was left oh do not
bring this into that well I mean don't
starve
what do you mean unfinished it was like
10 bajillion hours I could have done
fine we're did the craze but stabber
escape from is that like some slight to
me you're just trying to be
passive-aggressive telling me to beat
the game and whatever where did the
craze but Scabbers escape from Arkham
Asylum where did much dr. market market
agree he the technically doesn't have
one but which of these Oh
twirls of course Oh king of this world
physical world there's giant bag of bile
in here wait what how do you even know
this I don't even know what you're
talking about
ah God well I we gotta be good food I
know me which of these it's just easy
because if there's anything I have a
question about is like would I normally
say in this situation which of these is
not an oculus rift game turbo dismount
dude what did Martin art distract the
enemy players with during his rust
gameplay yo hey yodelling yeah totally
I will fort him with my yodeling skills
Wow oh my god this is like bringing up
so many memories us is so cool
Oh what they did mark hit - oh god I
think that was oh god why would I know
this why would I know this I don't know
this that was not long ago that was
actually March 52nd thank you it was
either the 6-2 the 24th I think it was a
six hey which of these phrases is not
commonly used by Mark II in my [ __ ] Oh
pops I've said that before let's say all
these things which one do I say the
least you my [ __ ] Oh pops hey open the
door get on the floor everybody do the
dinosaur what often happens to mark when
he records guys something about I'd just
like today where do these games was
inspired by surgeon simulator a beauty
in super amazing wagon adventure Mark
had the idea to try and jump over River
his idea turn out well of course yeah I
wish Wade died but he's stuck around
like a loser the whole goddamn game and
then screwed it up the end after
everyone else was already dead ah who's
Mark's favorite game of all time ooh
Rowley Arizona I like that but not my
favorite not my favorite of all time
definitely up there and which of these
games did Mark not say he will see us in
than oh now you're messin with me till I
set it a few times I've not said it a
few times but I'm not whole you oh wait
no I died in school of course I was it
there has been fan fish and written
about mark a new Oh everybody everybody
including the audience okay and what's
candid mark beg for gabe newell to save
him now you're reaching in the knowledge
that i what the hell on the world will I
know that ah
oh I thought it was they're like no call
me a loser like how long is this quiz
how much knowledge is there about my
life alright something in my eye that's
game predict the future okay
might have been houses are linger okay
mark has a two hour playthrough of me
beating SCP Oh H 7b I beat that on a
live stream because someone dared me to
and donated a lot to charity so there
you go alright what was Mark unable to
find in the very organized thief I found
everything don't tell me I did it I
found everything found the rare wine
there's the voice of the tablet okay so
boss god damn it this is really getting
hard why don't I know these things where
do you want me to die that was a fan
made game based on which game Mark had
played super squad simulator oh that was
awesome I love that one that was
amazingly done which of these games at
Marc play with a mod for more violence
doom of course brutal doom Marcos not
done which of these impossible Let's
Plays Russian Roulette challenge no no
don't even mention that because the
comments will think that's yours there's
no way I'm even gonna joke about doing
that that is dumb on a million different
levels don't even think about doing that
what character did Mark and Bob used to
skate with Isaac Clark what game is Mark
playing in the video title Santa's
rampage viscera cleanup that was an I
love doing that one maybe I'll do
another Christmas special this year with
Sir Claus has extensive knowledge
regarding what event in history
oh the formation of America of course
I'm an expert on the subject everyone
can ask me about that what did Mark not
do in his man time video uh let's
imagine watermelon with hammer no I did
it with my fists of fury he is video
proof of it
well there you go thank you everybody so
much for watching
whoa that's all Wednesday we'll see you
if no one knows if no one knows what
this is
I was stuck without my recording stuff
like I didn't have any I didn't have any
music and out yourself so I had to make
do so I made do with this ah Jesus Jesus
aha it's the outro but it's also musical
genius Leslie outro you can't be
stickler like that you douche like come
on there go
this must be musical genius right
yeah I'm a genius
I love it oh man thank you so much for
making this game it was like a trip down
memory lane it's just so great about
these fan games every time I play them
they have so many references to things
that I've done in the past and to some I
can't help but smile about it you guys
are amazing
I'm so amazed that some people have been
watching my videos for so long that they
know all this that's outstanding hey I
gotta go the credits granted by Jake
Nolan thank you so much Jake for making
this game that is absolutely awesome
there's a link to the game in the
description below if you want to take
the quiz and you don't remember these
questions and you really want to test
your mard blyer knowledge not that
that's valuable to any point in your
life there's no reason why you know that
stuff even I didn't know most of that
stuff but either way just thank you all
so much for being here and being awesome
people and playing this game with me and
just being awesome in general thank you
for making these fan games for me it's
an honor it's a privilege and an honor
so seriously thanks again everybody so
much for watching I'll check out the
other fan made games I'll put a bunch in
the description below along with any
other references in this video that I
think fit so thanks again everybody for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye
that's awesome but I feel really bad
because I feel like I missed out on
something